hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's the Halloween edition now
someone has told me that nothing that
happens in the Halloween edition is
actually can into the storyline of five
nights at Freddy's now that being said I
still have a sneaking suspicion that
there are secret things strewn about in
this game that are waiting to be
discovered but it may just spawn a whole
alternate timeline of events like Back
to the Future style you know change
everything and it's completely its own
entity but I still have a sneaking
suspicion that there are secrets yet to
be discovered but until I get to then
I'm gonna have to plow through the rest
of the game so what you're gonna see is
kind of a clip show highlight reel
montage of me failing and dying over and
over again while try to discover how the
new crew goes about their business
alright okay see you oh I love to play
this game I'm very good also in case you
guys didn't know the five nights at
freddies world trailer was released so
you guys can go watch that whenever you
feel like it I'm fun it's bizarre
reminds me of five nights of freak boys
well whatever hey I didn't do that I
didn't do that okay we're okay
everything's fine I'm not gonna die well
are they probably whoa what is that
wait a minute way hey now okay that's
mangle hi mangle how's it going in there
buddy are you doing can you shut the
[ __ ] up that'd be cool
oh he's such a little cutie I'm gonna
die haha I can't tell what is happening
oh god it's covering up all the noises
this is horrible
okay that I remember - okay
I'm gonna die coming in the kitchen
someone's in the kitchen
Oh mingle such a cute little [ __ ] Betsy
is kind of adorable if I wasn't so
panicking and worried about dying I'd be
more concerned about there I'd have more
time to celebrate I've been to [ __ ] you
oh oh oh hey almost got it got it I was
gonna
yay all right okay that's a win that's
the win in my book okay not too done so
as we've discovered mangle is the son of
a [ __ ]
mangle is a big pile of poo mangle sucks
donkey dong I don't like him oh look it
is halloween-themed he left without you
he knows that you hate it here you all
right beside the exit if you run you can
make it I know I gotta explore hurry run
towards the exit no I'm gonna go this
way
okay can't go that way what else we got
hi it's too late hurry the other way oh
oh oh that was it
that was the secret oh that's right if
you go back you see that's right oh I
didn't see that when I was playing it
for real before okay that's the thing
how's it going fredbear oh don't worry
I'm just gonna cry a lot
Morrow is another day what an optimistic
view on this horrible child's life not
the child's horrible the child's
horrible life I shouldn't be so mean to
this poor child
I wonder if they're gonna introduce the
marionette I wanna wake the baby I don't
want to wake the baby
I don't even know how to beat the baby
how do I beat the baby probably not
questions I should search shouting out
in the middle of the night how do I beat
this baby
was he there come on ah side of our
biscuit forgot how bad I was at this
game oh well again I go into the breach
orbit aha Oh God so at 12 a.m. mangle
you son of a [ __ ] don't you dip up oh
hey oh how you doing go ask yourself ah
mangle would you mind shutting the hell
up for just one moment please
I'm trying to listen for death death is
very important to conquer hello hi death
how's it going
you're ne er wait oh wow whoa oh I
forgot he's oh oh he's more active on
this night a knee oh my god go away oh
jeez don't give me that smile
I didn't hear I can't it's mango how can
I uh
god dammit how am I supposed to be able
to hear how how am I supposed to be able
to hear a damn thing Oh God oh I mean I
don't want to be that guy but maybe I'm
gonna have to use some cheat codes to be
able to get through this I'm gonna be
that guy aren't I now I can do it
I am the king no one will take my crown
for me no Zeke
I was in the middle uh I was in the
middle of changing my action
oh god my instincts are all off ah I
pressed the wrong button
ah hi mangle welcome to the party hi
okay cool cool cool cool freely our dear
Phil your dear really are to use my ears
to hear Oh hate you and your stupid face
it's so scary
ah
I just don't know I don't know what that
front right I don't know what to trust
anymore but I'm too good for you mango
that's what I thought we get duped Lee
look okay okay okay okay okay okay
oh come on Jimmy Christmas
hahaha that's so hard you guys don't
understand when mangle gets in the room
it's so hard well actually you probably
perfectly understand you didn't hear
everything I can hear it's so hard to do
it's so hard oh man
Oh for a little kid
ah oh how did it happen there was a way
there yo okay Fred beer and friends look
mines foxy there
oh no okay Fred bear and friends hi
honey
again I didn't find this on my normal
playthrough all right there way okay
that's all I got
nothing new hi that's going are you
doing you good good
Oh oh come on that's such bull it's such
bull touch Bo so hard that is hard
obviously because if you want to do the
challenge modes I'm willing to bet that
the challenge modes are purely
impossible if you don't have the Balloon
Boy bonus how are you going on there so
that's nice oh look at that see see in
the background it's a hospital bag
hanger as they're called in the medical
field bag hangers of course I know what
it's called yes nurse it is a bag hanger
I'm a doctor oh come on
I have wrecked this night I've wrecked
it my you late a man I dare okay that
was a big breath chica in my ear yes you
can get away with a lot okay what I've
learned is blind mode I was curious
about that could you play the whole game
blind you can actually do a lot just by
sitting in your room and listening you
don't have to go up and check the doors
in the early nights just because you
know there's there's not a lot going on
you can actually listen to where they
are oh hey this is fun please let me out
I'm scared in here and for good reason
please oh man poor kid
ha ha ha soon as I heard his step come
on
you suck uh sounds that sounds different
that doesn't sound like that sounds like
Fred bear
oh oh no no no right bear
why was he here what my father
oh yeah vibes only fredbear I forgot I'm
an idiot undergo or do ah actually hang
on okay I want to see
I really am curious because fredbear is
such a [ __ ] douche
you always hear him scampering all
around I want to see what he looks like
on the map like what does it actually
look like
why isn't he showing up on the map oh
there is oh that was his fakie steps
what a bunch of baloney this game is
rigged
Oh order all ooh oh ah ah
there was no sound of that one so I get
it okay this actually helps me
understand the mechanic he goes to one
side or he switches inside and then it's
like a timer as he's coming down that
hallway so it's when you don't hear him
switch that you know he's coming down
that hallway that makes much more sense
ah that's really cool that actually
gives me some insight into how he works
so if he was oh he didn't why didn't he
go away damn it
well he was still an idiot okay but that
actually gives some insight onto how he
works he he's very intricate okay that
makes so much sense
ha ha ha ha so you got to hold the door
until it goes away obviously I just
didn't do that cuz I'll tell you 10 to
the mavin I beg reduce so there are more
secrets to find I know there are there's
more content to explore there's more
scares to be had so thank you everybody
so much for watching check out the
annotation for more five nights at
Freddy's and other scary games that I
played in the past and as always I will
see you in the next video
what the [ __ ] okay go through six hours
and I scrapped why did I come back for
another line